so we're told that the first four terms
of a geometric sequence are given so
they give us the first four terms they
say what is the fifth term in the
sequence and like always pause the video
and see if you can come up with the
fifth term
well all we have to remind ourselves is
for a geometric sequence
for a geometric sequence each successive
term is the previous term multiplied by
some number and that number we call the
common ratio so let's think about it to
go from negative 132nd that's the first
term to
1 8 what do we have to multiply by
what do we have to multiply by let's see
we're going to multiply it's going to be
multiplied by a negative since we went
from a negative to a positive so we're
going to multiply
we're going to multiply by negative and
then it's going to be a 1 over
let's see to go from a 32 to an 8
actually it's not going to be a 1 over
it's going to be
this is this is 4 times as large as that
it's going to be negative 4. negative
132 times negative 4 is
positive 1 8. just to just to make that
clear negative 1 32nd
times
negative 4. that's the same thing as
negative 4 over 1 it's going to be
positive negative times a negative is a
positive positive 4 over 32 which is
equal to 1 8. and let's see if that
holds up so to go from 1 8 to negative
one-half we once again would multiply by
negative four
negative four times one-eighth is
negative four-eighths which is negative
one-half
and so then we multiply by negative four
again so
let me make it clear we're multiplying
by negative 4 each time you multiply by
negative 4 again you get to positive 2
because negative 4
negative negative 4 over negative 2 you
can view it that way is positive 2. and
so to get the fifth term in the sequence
we would multiply by negative 4 again
and so 2 times negative 4 is
negative 8. negative 4 is the common
ratio for this geometric sequence but
just to answer the question what is the
fifth term it is going to be
negative eight